la page environnement de cette édition
avec les abeilles qui vont conquérir
saint quentin en yvelines après les sept
ruches inauguré il ya quelques mois à
l'hôtel d'agglomération la ville de la
verrière elle aussi a dorénavant son
rucher après la communauté
d'agglomération en avril le week-end
dernier c'était au tour de la verrière
d'inaugurer son rucher dans le cadre de
l'opération nationale abeille sentinelle
de l'environnement un message politique
et citoyen selon alain ajaj maire de la
commune s'intéressaient de s'interroger
sur les conditions de la biodiversité
sur notre territoire national et
régional et local et donc on sait
qu'aujourd'hui cette biodiversité est en
danger il y à des risques de voir tous
les phénomènes naturels perturbé par la
pollution les pesticides conséquences
graves pour l'environnement la
disparition des abeilles depuis
plusieurs années et sans ces insectes
pollinisateurs
on peut dire adieu à notre agriculture
selon l'union nationale de l'apiculture
française grâce à leur action les
abeilles génère chaque année un chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 3 milliards d'euros
soit plus de 30% de ce qu'on consomme
proviennent du rôle des abeilles par la
pollinisation
parmi la population la bei maintenant
les enjeux convenant de rabais et sont
vraiment perçu par la population et les
politiques se dit qu'effectivement il
faut prendre des décisions pour arriver
à sauvegarder abeilles parce qu'on est
passé d'un taux de mortalité était
environ 5 % il ya encore quinze ou vingt
ans à un taux de mentalité de plus de
30% par an l'installation des ruches
ferriérois sera complétée par des
prairies fleuries afin que les abeilles
puisse butiné des actions pédagogiques
seront organisées avec les écoles de la
ville
et pour les gourmands sachez que le miel
sera récoltée à l'occasion des apidays
au mois de juin prochaine inauguration
de ruchers sur le territoire de saint
quentin au printemps il s'agira cette
fois de la ville de montigny retour sur
le plateau du 7-8 en direct entre 18 et
19 heures et si je précise en direct
c'est tout simplement parce que maxime
le maine m'a rejoint
oui ils remonteront
mais alors pas vos invités et non les
invités vont arriver dans quelques
instants ce sont les aléas du direct et
donc nous parleront d'une manifestation
qui a eu lieu à versailles samedi une
manifestation de tracteurs nous avons
quelques images qui vont apparaître dans
quelques instants
effectivement mais on voit quelques
images les agriculteurs sont donc en
colère ils ont manifesté ce week-end où
les raisons de leurs revendications
alors les raisons fait tout simplement
parce que depuis plusieurs années dans
les yvelines et dans l'essonne puisque
c'étaient des agriculteurs de living et
de l'essonne l'urbain prend le pas sur
les terres agricoles et donc les
syndicats d'agriculteurs notamment la
coordination rurale ile de france pour
les yvelines et la coordination rurale
ile-de-france pour l'essonne se bat pour
préserver leur mode de vie
selon les mots de jean noël rejoint sarr
qui devra nous rejoindre d'ici quelques
instants
il n'avait pas fait carrière comme des
comme des indiens dans une réserve
qu'ils aimeraient bien voilà il arrive
nous accueillons donc sur ce plateau
jean noël en or en sari et didier
ardouin respectivement président de la
coordination rurale ile de france dont
pour les yvelines et secrétaire général
de la coordination rurale ile de france
le président de la coordination rurale
bord le département de l'essonne voilà
alors mais salue les soirées bienvenue
bonsoir mais ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi quelles sont les
raisons de cette colère pourquoi être
allé manifester rencontré le préfet
samedi à versailles
parce que ou s'interrogent sur l'avenir
de
de l'agriculture en ile de france les
agriculteurs d'île de france et c'est un
grand souci pour nous de savoir vraiment
est ce que vraiment garder une
agriculture en ile de france c'est ça le
problème avec les grands projets le
grand paris les hauts vienne l'opération
d'intérêt national c'est plateau de
saclay plateau de saclay notamment la
vallée de la vallée de la seine où c'est
une emprise depuis 3500 hectares donc
150 mille logements qui va représenter
pour les yvelines plus de 40 % de
population opus donc à l'heure actuelle
ce qui se passe et qu'on centralise trop
dans le sens région d'île de france
qu'il faudrait plutôt décentralisée et
on fait tout le contraire 1 on nous dit
toujours oui on va préserver les espaces
agricoles mais c'est pas le cas à
l'heure actuelle il ya aussi les projets
de lgv donc le lgv notamment aussi bien
dans l'essonne
car montferrand orléans ou paris loire
nous sommes tout à fait opposés à ces
projets on attend prendre les voit ici
102 les voies ferrées existantes
parce qu'on sait très bien s'ils font
une lgv donc tgv c'est forcément des
infrastructures qui vont se faire autour
du lgv des lgv alors didier ardouin
est-ce que quelle est votre opinion sur
ce qu'ils vont me dire jean noël
rouinsard c'est à dire que là les
conditions de vie des agriculteurs se
dégradent vraiment dans le dans votre
département également
les sommes tout à fait c'est la même
chose des vêtements le département de
l'essonne et les yvelines comme le val
d'oise
c'est l'ancien rennais voit donc la
scène s'est passée dans la main dans ce
combat on n'a qu'une chambre
d'agriculture de l'ancien cd voit ce qui
est dans les yvelines
et voilà le même combat la même chose
les mêmes problèmes on en perd rurbaine
on a un problème de l'élevage
aujourd'hui les éleveurs arrête un
parent chez nous plus un éleveur il y
aura plus un seul éleveur pour nous a
mis des contrôles il faut cinq contrôles
par département pour l'élevage du
contrôle de pâques il ya plus de deux
éleveurs donc se construit deux à trois
fois par an les jeunes vous avez le
sentiment d'être persécuté
oui en temps vous en particulier avec
ses systèmes et c'est pour ça qu'on a
demandé à monsieur le préfet de pouvoir
avoir un les contrôles soient mis par
rapport à la sonde la culture comme dans
les autres départements
et en plus ça fait des années on avait
été reçu par monsieur barnier ministre
de l'agriculture il ya six ans c'est ça
six entraînements il ya trois ans tous
trois ont été reçus la dernière
manifestation qu'on avait fait onze mois
la responsabilité incombe à vous menez
depuis longtemps et puis ça fait très
longtemps donc non exactement ça fait
plus de vingt ans qu'on mène le combat
pour préserver des ventes les espaces
agricoles et donc on a des structures
une friture département par département
plus une structure régionale dont je
suis le président parce que je suis à la
fois le président de l'union des
syndicats des coordinations râle
d'ile-de-france plus le président de la
crd yvelines et membre de la chambre
d'agriculture
l'île de france est aussi nous
travaillons nous travaillons aussi en
synthétique avec ce collectif sont les
yvelines que vous avez reçu l'année
dernière dont vous avez reçu oui
effectivement qui est moi je suis
vice-président puisqu'on travaille aussi
en synthétique avec le collectif sauvons
les évident notamment pour les
infrastructures l'urbanisation intensive
donc une grosse organisation voit bien
juris président donc 1300 adhérents pour
le second les idées le jeune wallon à ça
j'ai lu dans une interview vous avez
donnée au parisien que je me disais tout
à l'heure vous aviez l'impression que
les agriculteurs ont finalement
peut-être finir comme des indiens dans
une réserve c'est vraiment un sentiment
vous allez on resserre l'étau vous avez
paul tort c'est ça oui parce que c'est
une chose que j'avais dit au préfet
erignac feu le préfet erignac est
effectivement j'avais dit à l'époque on
est déjà rendu bradeurs et c'est
aujourd'hui d'époque forcément et on
avait quand même plus de 18 ans grenade
avance et c'est ça le problème donc
surprend connaître l'agriculture
d'ile-de-france en intermède ça nous
permet de nous mieux nous protéger
d'avoir un espace agricole vont pouvoir
continuer à avoir des jeunes qu'ils
puissent continuer derrière parce que
c'est ça aussi c'est les jeunes qui
puisse continuer à reprendre nos
exploitations les chiffres dévoilés
moins en moins de familles et à moins en
moins de famille est ce qu'il faut
regarder c'est le poumon vert c'est ça
qu'il faut garder à l'ouest parisien
aussi bien dans l'essonne au nord et au
sud de maintenir une agriculture de
proximité
parce qu'il faut savoir que dans les
années futures les coûts des transports
vont coûter très très cher si on
agriculture de proximité avec des
circuits courts et les éleveurs les
maraîchers l'arboriculture et tout un
ensemble de spécialiser ça nous permet
de nourrir une population parce qu'avant
la vocation d'ouvrir un peu plus loin
vous parlez de circuits courts
finalement vous parlez d'un système
économique à mettre en place mais pour
l'instant on voit bien qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de produits agricoles qui
viennent de l'étranger et de l'union
européenne serre que vous vos clients
pour l'instant qui sont-ils et star est
ce que vous arrivez encore à vendre vos
produits il ya des producteurs qui comme
hostile que mons avandia des éleveurs
qui vendent leur viande mais le problème
de des abattoirs parce que ça aussi
c'est le sujet c'est que l'on n'a plus
qu'un abattoir hameau esponde mans nous
depuis très très longtemps avait demandé
à michel barnier au mr culture d'avoir
un abattoir mobile comme ça se passe en
allemagne ce qui permettrait à réduire
ce qui permettrait de réduire le coût
des transports est donc aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle a beaucoup qui vont sur
des abattoirs d'alençon est pas le coût
des transports ça coûte beaucoup plus
cher et et vendre leur viande en direct
auprès des consommateurs on l'a pas
précisé tout à l'heure il me semble on
peut parler de vos activités respectives
alors vous êtes
cet agriculteur éleveur expliquez nous
non je suis agriculteur céréalier
betteraviers passé dans les salons et
betteraviers depuis toujours ses râles
betteraviers pommes de terre d'accord
mais pourquoi je suis si les difficultés
notamment dans les transports notamment
pour se déplacer dans les yvelines en
ile de france parce que ça c'est pour
tout le monde pareil aussi bien dans
tous les départs trois départements
puissent leval demain et c'est quand
même le transport c'est quand même très
important c'est des coups en plus et
provinces et des problèmes de sécurité
parce que c'est quand on sait pas s'il
ya toujours un problème de sécurité et
pour accéder à nos parcelles c'est pas
évident alors il ya aussi un autre souci
aussi c'est que à l'heure actuelle le
conseil général des yvelines
notamment il est bon les produits
d'infrastructure l'avait fait m
parce que j'ai parlé la voie nouvelle de
la moule il ya aussi les voies vertes
donc les voies vertes cd voit vert si
vous avez des chemins ruraux
on les met en voie communale il voit
combien on y voit vert donc c'est du
béton dans la peine alors nous on n'en
veut pas parce que ça va à l'encontre de
notre activité professionnelle et en
plus il vaut mieux laisser les chemins
naturel que les gens puissent se
promener faire comme d'habitude à l'état
sauvage appel ci puissent se promener en
vo faire du vélo à pied les randonnées
etc
c'est que de figer du béton c'est pas
bon et faire des rivières dans les
fermes
voilà c est payant plus et des décharges
et c'est tout tous les problèmes qu'on
rencontre à l'heure actuelle il ya
beaucoup de décharge de en échange il ya
une question que je me pose quand on
aborde ce type de sujet puisqu'on en
parle souvent en plateau dans la
chronique environnement aussi c'est à
dire que ça fait des années que vous
aborder ces thèmes avec des responsables
politiques des responsables associatifs
est ce qu'à un moment il va falloir
choisir un mode d'action peut-être plus
dur que ce que vous faites maintenant
c'est à dire ce que vous avez vraiment
sentiment d'être d'être entendu dans une
économie mondialisée telle qu'elle
existe actuellement
parce que là pour l'instant on en est au
stade des abymes manifestations il ya
d'autres réunions prévues notamment 15
novembre le cas je vends
un groupe de travail avec le préfet avec
les associations d'environnement parce
que nous savons faire bouger les choses
a fait très chaud parce qu'il faut aller
dans le sens que prône maxime semble
prôner maxis et l'arrêt se sont essayés
autrement est différente par rapport à
d'autres ouais on va le dire
ça fait des années qu'on travaille
d'associations notamment sur les points
d'urbanisation d'infrastructures l on le
fait parce qu'il ya forcément dans le
combat qu'on mène 6 à une force faut
dire dans un collectif y aller ce biais
les élus le monde associatif particulier
et y est nous mêmes les agriculteurs
donc
donc si c'est ça c'est autre chose et
quand dans nos assemblées notre
assemblée générale ces associations ils
viennent y voit une agriculture
différemment et autrement
et là c'est beaucoup plus porteur et ils
se rencontrent des difficultés qu'on a
des choses qu'on a des difficultés en
ile de france et c'est là dessus ça
change des choses et lâches ou ce qui
est un changement et même toute
organisation professionnelle devra aller
dans ce sens là et c'est ce qu'on fait
nous merci jean noël ransart merci
didier ardouin donc de la coordination
rurale ile-de-france d'être finalement
venu jusqu'à nous malgré les difficultés
vous avez réussi à nous rejoindre et
merci maxime vous avez une petite
frayeur pour votre dernière chronique
et oui tout parce que c'était votre
dernière chronique tout à fait le fruit
c'était ma dernière chronique puisque je
pars vers d'autres aventures
professionnelles et je tiens vraiment à
remercier toute la rédaction de tv fils
la direction également qui m'a donné ma
première opportunité en tant que
journaliste et grâce à soyez pas si le
risque maximum parce que le présentateur
merci ce magnétisme et bercy en tout cas
pacsés bientôt merci à vous et est
forcément d'un petit cadeau au lieu de
faire un long discours on va regarder un
petit cadeau en images voilà une petite
séquence pitt compilation préparé par
romain respini mais vous saviez pas à
l'offre alléchante
regardez attention quelques secondes
d'observation
vous avez envie de tout laisser tomber
pour retourner à la peur bonjour à tous
et bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
équilibre le magazine du relou qui vont
dans les arbres
c'est formidable c'est génial
s'équilibre c'est parti c'est parti
c'est parti c'est parfait
c'est parti c'est parti c'est parti pas
question de jouer aux apprentis sorciers
on ne s'improvise pas expert en
problèmes environnementaux a passé l'an
dernier rappelle pour l'embarquement à
destination du sud
vous l'aurez peut-être remarqué c'est la
période pour les oiseaux migrateurs
mais qu'est ce qu'il se passe alors
c'est bien beau tout ça mais qu'est ce
que ça signifie bienvenue dans la
quatrième dimension du globe bon qu'on
connait rien c'est normal je ne souhaite
pas toujours très claires imaginez que
vous êtes une abeille vous écoutez
regardez ce sujet vous allez comprendre
sujet sujet sujet 3
abricot c'est bon tu l'as pas nous faire
une tâche non plus et si je vous dis
corps à corps à pouvoir aux femmes
quand on partait sur les chemins à
bicyclette
maxime vous n'avez pas bonnes moeurs et
si je me suis mis la tête dans la loge
est née puis bon ça va pas marcher
c'est quand même bien faire
une belle aire linguistique story c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est mon caleçon
pour disent ils apporteront bien thomas
ciao bye ciao ciao ciao bella ciao bye
est tout de suite je pars dire de
nouvelles aventures courir dans mon
cercle tout comme tintin bonne soirée
merci max et vous
les aventures de maxima téléphiles le
livre qui se referme merci merci merci
beaucoup collaboration pendant pendant
presque deux ans plus de deux ans même à
téléfilm merci à vous et puis bonne
continuation pour la pour la suite comme
il est coutume de dire c'est la fin de
cette édition du 7 8 je retrouve de
moins en direct à 18h avec deux nouveaux
invités excellente soirée et c'est bon
de soirée bonne soirée
à demain 18h non on va continuer
l'émission encore maxime et bien on
continue à les voilà c'est parti on est
partis pour plusieurs heures de direct
je vous laisse les clés maximois genre
on s'arrête ici où s'arrête pas ici que
ces longues soirées en tout cas voilà
merci